[Musique]
cette vidéo est destinée aux étudiants
de prépa ECG anciennement prépa HEC en
effet les épreuves de dissertation de
culture générale des concours des
grandes écoles de commerce qui auront
lieu l'année prochaine en 2024 ces
épreuves de dissertation porteront sur
le thème de la violence deux petites
précisions avant de vous lire ma
dissertation modèle tout d'abord vous
pouvez télécharger le texte de cette
dissertation pour l'obtenir cliquez sur
le lien qui apparaît en haut à droite de
la vidéo ou bien cliquez sur celui qui
est dans la description ou bien encore
taper directement 1000 idées
cg.com/volence dans la barre de
recherche ensuite il vous suffira de
vous inscrire avec votre adresse email
de confirmer votre inscription en
ouvrant le premier email que vous
recevrez et vous recevrez alors ma
dissertation dans l'e-mail suivant s'il
y a un souci vous pouvez m'écrire à
romain@mi l'idée cg.com seconde
précision préliminaire inspirée par le
fait que pas mal d'élèves m'ont déjà
posé la même question oui je vais bien
proposer mes 50 paragraphes tout cuits
sur le thème de la violence comme chaque
année il n'y a que 100 places c'est
pourquoi certains élèves déjà réservé la
leur si ça vous intéresse cliquez sur le
lien qui apparaît en haut à droite de la
vidéo ou bien cliquez sur celui qui est
dans la description ou bien encore taper
directement 1000 idées
cg.com/50ptc dans la barre de recherche
bien sûr vous pouvez me poser vos
questions par email en écrivant à Romain
@mider cg.com voilà voilà c'est bon pour
les précisions préliminaires je vais
maintenant vous lire ma dissertation
modèle sur le sujet la violence
la sexologue américaine Suzanne bloc
réhabilite le cri pacifiste des années
1960 faites l'amour pas la guerre dans
la voie du bonobo l'évolution de la paix
par le plaisir elle exhorte les hommes
du 21e siècle à s'inspirer de leur plus
proche cousin génétique il devrait
résoudre leurs conflits et renforcer les
liens sociaux en multipliant les
rapports sexuels ce plaidoyer en
apparence utopique invite à questionner
la nature de la violence humaine le
Dictionnaire de l'Académie française est
distingue deux sens essentielles du nom
commun violence c'est tout d'abord la
force elle-même plus précisément le fait
d'agir sur quelqu'un ou de le faire agir
contre sa volonté en employant la force
ou l'intimidation la violence parentale
qui se manifeste dans la fessée par
exemple le second sens essentiel du mot
violence et le fait que la force ne soit
pas contenue et qu'elle risque par là
d’engendrer un dommage la violence d'un
coup de pied par exemple enfin le mot
désigne le plus souvent la violence
physique mais elle peut également être
psychologique les hommes semblent
éprouver une aversion naturelle pour la
violence il la condamne spontanément si
la vie sociale moderne ne ressemble pas
encore à la foire sexuelle des bonobos
les mentalités occidentales obéissent
cependant à un puissante idéal de non
violence cette idéale transparaît aussi
bien dans la perception des enjeux
militaires par l'opinion publique dans
la vie économique dans l'éducation dans
le traitement des animaux que dans de
banal conflits entre particuliers les
esprits modernes tolèrent de moins en
moins la violence
istigmatise par exemple les
micro-agressions leur sensibilité
s'exercerbe au point d'assimiler tout
rapport d'autorité à une forme de
violence comment expliquer cette
répugnance peut-être s'agit-il d'un
penchant inné de l'esprit humain faut-il
en déduire que l'agression est une
anomalie une exception pathologique dans
la vie sociale cette hypothèse paraît
peu crédible étant donné l’abondance et
la diversité des phénomènes de violence
dans l'histoire serait alors au
contraire une dimension incontournable
du destin de l'humanité la violence
humaine est-elle une AB erration si les
hommes répugnent naturellementent à la
violence elle paraît cependant ancrée
dans le registre ordinaire de leur
comportement mais la propension à la
violence de l'humanité semble
inexorablement s'étioler
la version spontanée pour la violence
serait naturelle parce que l'agression
constituerait une déviation du
comportement humain en premier lieu la
violence est contraire aux besoins de
sécurité cette idée vaut pour tous les
animaux pas seulement pour l'homme en
effet un organisme vivant diffère d'un
rocher ou d'une rivière en ce qui la
tendance à rendre coup pour coup tout
agression implique donc un risque de
réplique immédiate sans parler des
représailles futurs en suivant ce
raisonnement l'impératif de survie doit
empêcher les comportements violents
c'est pour cette raison que Rousseau
imagine un état de nature pacifique il
part de l’idée que la conservation de la
vie est le premier et le plus important
des soins pour tout animal y compris
l'être humain ce qu'il appelle l'amour
de soi l'instinct de conservation qui
habite tout être vivant l'amour de soi
inspire une répugnance innée à l'égard
de la violence Rousseau en déduit que
l'homme naturel cherche uniquement à se
protéger je cite les hommes étaient
plutôt farouches que méchants et plus
attentif à se garantir du mal qu'il
pouvait recevoir que tenter d'en faire à
autrui Discours sur l'origine de
l'inégalité la logique de la survie
disqualifie donc la violence comme une
déviation du comportement humain
mais l'amour de soi n'est pas le seul
frein à l'agression non seulement
l'homme prend un risque en attaquant un
autre animal mais il est lié à ces
semblable par un sentiment spécial il
est capable de se mettre à leur place
par la pensée de ressentir leurs
émotions en particulier de souffrir
lorsqu'il les voit souffrir et
d'harmoniser ses intérêts avec les leurs
la tradition philosophique occidentale a
donné divers noms à se penchant c'est
par exemple la sympathie dans la théorie
morale d’adam Smith les psychologues
scientifiques parlent eux d'empathie le
destin de Jean Valjean dans Les
Misérables en est une bonne illustration
ce personnage un força échappé du bagne
était pourtant prédisposée à la
psychopathie par son passé violent mais
la générosité de l’évêque Myriel à son
égard le rend altruiste Jean Valjean
promettent à Fantine une pauvre femme
mourante de prendre soin de causette sa
fille exploitée par un couple
d'aubergistes les thénardiers il sauvera
même l'inspecteur qu'il avait arrêté
javère lors d'une insurrection
parisienne cet exemple montre que
l'empathie est une force qui s'oppose à
la violence
enfin il semble que l'intérêt collectif
se superpose aux tendances individuelles
la violence pose en effet un problème
essentiel à toute communauté humaine
elle trouble la coopération si les
membres ne se font plus confiance s'ils
se craignent les uns les autres alors
ils ne peuvent plus s'entendre en vue
d'un but commun ils ne peuvent plus
produire des richesses créer de l'art
enrichir leur vie sociale ni améliorer
leur organisation pour la rendre plus
juste cette idée suggère que la
pacification des rapports humains et la
condition du bonheur de la collectivité
Voltaire emploie cet argument dans son
Traité sur la tolérance il pointe
surtout du doigt le fanatisme chrétien
qui commet la violence au nom d'un
prophète qui prenait la non-violence or
la diversité des cultes favorise aussi
bien la prospérité de la population que
celle de l'État le commerce et
l'agriculture y ont gagné et crie
Voltaire à propos de la tolérance
religieuse et le corps politique n'en a
jamais souffert ainsi la tolérance est
avantageuse parce que la violence
entrave la prospérité
les hommes répugnent donc naturellement
à l'agression aussi bien par intérêt
commun que par des tendances
individuelles cette conclusion doit
néanmoins être mise à l'épreuve des
faits les phénomènes de violence ne sont
ni rares ni limitées dans l'histoire de
l'humanité
[Musique]
petite interruption parce que je me dis
que si tu m'écoutes c'est pas pour
devenir philosophe professionnel non tu
m'écoutes parce que tu veux te préparer
de la manière la plus efficace qui soit
pour réussir tes dissertations de
culture générale et du coup je me dis
que tu as probablement compris qu'un
cours de 300 pages n'est pas la solution
au contraire c'est plutôt le problème si
tu as conscience de ce problème alors
j'ai une solution pour toi chaque année
je prépare 50 paragraphes modèle sur le
thème que j'ai baptisé avec un brin de
provocation 50 paragraphes tout cuits
l'idée est simple tu n'as plus besoin de
rédiger toi-même le développement de tes
dissertations puisque tu connais déjà
une cinquantaine de paragraphes très
rédigé qui permettent de défendre tous
les arguments envisageables sur tous les
sujets envisageables avec les références
idéales et si je sais que ça marche pour
tous les sujets c'est parce que je
traite moi-même tous les sujets
possibles dans un premier temps c'est
comme ça que je trouvais les arguments
des paragraphes d'ailleurs depuis
plusieurs années je fournis avec les
paragraphes une cinquantaine de plans
détaillés modèles les avantages de cette
solution c'est que tu n'as plus besoin
de cours que tu n'as plus besoin de
chercher un plan ni des arguments et que
tu seras surnauté parce que les
paragraphes sont bien mieux rédigés que
si tu les rédigé toi-même ce qui fait
que ta copie sort du lot les élèves me
disent aussi qu'ils sont beaucoup moins
stressés pendant l'épreuve qu'il se
sentent confiant et à l'aise bref mais
50 paragraphes tout cuits te feront
gagner facilement et rapidement des
points tout en gagnant beaucoup de temps
ce qui te permet de gagner des points
dans les autres matières tout
particulièrement en maths si tu veux en
savoir plus clique sur le lien qui
apparaît en haut à droite de la vidéo ou
bien clique sur celui qui est dans la
description ou bien encore tape
directement mais l'idée
cg.com/50ptc dans la barre de recherche
et puis si tu as des questions écris-moi
à romain@mi l'idée cg.com
la réalité de la violence crédibilise
l'idée selon laquelle l'agression serait
ancrée dans le registre ordinaire du
comportement humain cette idée s’éclaire
tout d'abord comme celle de la
répugnonce naturelle à la violence à la
lumière du primat de la survie survivre
demande certes de vivre en sécurité mais
les enjeux concrets de la coexistence
des êtres vivants sont plus complexes
par exemple un organisme à intérêt à
risquer d'en agresser un autre pour ne
pas mourir de faim ou encore pour éviter
une atteinte ultérieure plus grave à son
intégrité physique telle est d'après la
théorie des jeux la logique naturelle
des représailles elle protège leurs
auteurs contre de futurs agressions hop
ce conçoit un état de nature hostile à
partir de cette même logique l'homme de
la préhistoire n'ignore pas le danger
inhérent à toute initiative violente
seulement il est persuadé que les autres
vont l'agresser il a donc intérêt à
prendre lui-même l'initiative d'attaquer
c'est à dire qu'il attaque par
anticipation les hommes de l'état de
nature conclu Ops je cite son dans cette
condition qui se nomme guerre et cette
guerre et guerre de chacun contre chacun
Léviathan son argumentation montre ainsi
que la survie peut également favoriser
l'agression
mais là encore les passions humaines se
mêlent à l'impératif de survie de la
même manière qu'il existe un penchant
altruiste il existe également un
penchant à vouloir l'infortune d'autrui
il se manifeste notamment dans la quête
de l'honneur ou du statut social dans la
terminologie moderne l'homme veut être
reconnu et respecté par ces semblables
ce désir est si fort qu'il est prêt à
recourir à l'agression pour l'accomplir
l'intrigue du Cid de Corneille est un
exemple classique du rôle de l'honneur
dans la violence humaine au début de la
pièce le père de Chimène donne Gomes
insulte le père de Don Rodrigues don
dieg en lui donnant une gifle ce faisant
il bafoue l'honneur de la famille de Don
Rodrigues celui-ci est alors contraint
de venger l'honneur de son père en
défiant en duel don Gomes le père de la
femme qu'il aime il le tue bien que cela
puisse lui coûter son amour pour Chimène
que de mots et de pleurs nous coûterons
nos pères s'écrit-il bien conscient de
la logique pernicieuse de l'honneur qui
enchait sur l'impératif de survie
rendu crédible par la psychologie
individuelle l'hypothèse d'un penchant
humain naturel à l'agression devient
encore plus convaincante en considérant
les comportements collectifs malgré ses
conséquences désastreuses la guerre
n'est pas un phénomène exceptionnel au
contraire elle est un fond omniprésent
dans l'histoire des civilisations des
groupes humains organisés ne cessent de
prendre les armes les uns contre les
autres l'Odyssée d'Homère offre par
exemple un aperçu du rapport des hommes
de la Grèce antique à la guerre ils
voient les conflits militaires comme un
aspect inexorable de l'existence leur
fatalisme transparaît dans le fait
qu'ils imputent la guerre à la colère
des dieux plutôt que de l'envisager
comme un problème humain soluble nous
sommes des hommes se lamentent Ulysse
acquises Zeus je le vois inflige le
destin de dévider le fil des guerres
douloureuses les Grecs de l’antiquité
vivent ainsi dans l’hypothèse d'une mort
soudaine et violente les femmes guettent
avec inquiétude à l'horizon dévoile
annonciatrices d'un tournant tragique
dans leur vie l'agression militaire
passe à cette époque pour un événement
naturel dans la vie collective la guerre
la logique de l'honneur et la prédation
accrédite donc l'idée que l'agression
serait inscrite dans le registre
ordinaire du comportement humain cette
conclusion nous incline au pessimisme
toutefois elle ne signifie pas que les
hommes seront à jamais prisonniers de
leur propre violence
en observant l'histoire sur le temps
long il apparaît en réalité que la
propension à la violence de l'humanité
semble inexorablement s'étiolée la
raison la plus évidente de cette
évolution serait l'émergence d'État
stable en effet ce développement
politique de l'humanité transforme les
rapports entre individus et entre
groupes ils sont désormais contraints de
résoudre leur conflit par
l'intermédiaire d'institution et de
processus légaux plutôt que par la
violence l'évolution a déjà commencé en
Europe lorsque hops se prône à
l'instauration d'un état assez fort pour
interdire les violences privées elle se
poursuit au XVIIIe siècle jusqu'à ce que
l'État conquiert selon la fameuse
définition de Max Weber dans le savant
et le politique le monopole de la
violence légitime le sociologue part du
constat que le recours à la violence
physique est un moyen normal d'exercice
du pouvoir dans tous les groupements
politiques or ce moyen était fragmenté
en Occident jusqu'à la fin du Moyen-Âge
l'État moderne est donc l'aboutissement
d'un processus d'expropriation politique
l'origine du processus et la volonté du
prince d'exproprié les puissances
privées indépendantes qui à côté de lui
détenait un pouvoir administratif au
bout du processus seuls les agents de
l'autorité publique sont autorisés à
manier la force
cette explication convaincante et
cependant partiel en effet non seulement
les citoyens des États occidentaux
contemporains n'ont pas le droit d'être
violent mais dans leur immense majorité
ils n'en n'ont pas du tout envie il
condamne l'agression et la stigmatise
jusque dans le langage commente élucider
l'allergie à la violence de l'homme
moderne Norbert Elias mettant lumière
une profonde évolution des mentalités de
nouvelles normes sociales se sont
propagées dans les sociétés européennes
depuis la fin du Moyen-Âge au point de
transformer la psychologie individuelle
en l'espace de quelques siècles les
Européens ont appris à inhiber leur
pulsion à anticiper les conséquences à
long terme et à considérer les pensées
et sentiments d'autrui la culture de
l'honneur légitimement la vengeance a
été remplacée par une culture de la
dignité qui valorise la maîtrise de soi
on faisait un art de se moucher décrit
Elias le point de perfection consistait
à ne fait un ni trop de bruit ni trop
peu la civilisation des mœurs le nouvel
idéal de la civilité c'est propager des
aristocrates et chevaliers aux autres
classes jusqu'à intégrer finalement la
culture dans son ensemble dès lors la
morale sociale dévalorise la violence
la stigmatisation de la violence semble
toutefois épargner la guerre l'illusion
révélée par la formule apocryphe de
Staline selon laquelle je cite la mort
d'un homme est une tragédie la mort d'un
million d'hommes est une statistique
cette illusion résisterait au processus
de civilisation reconstituée par Elias
il paraît difficile voire indécent de
défendre l'idée d'un déclin de la
violence humaine après les horreurs
commises au 20e siècle en particulier
celle des deux guerres mondiales mais
l'idée n'est pas déraisonnable une fois
qu'on l'examine d'un point de vue
comptable la violence guerrière du
siècle dernier est moindre rapporté à la
population totale et en prenant en
compte les effets indirects des guerres
du passé tels que les famines et les
maladies de surcroît elle a traumatisé
la conscience collective la diplomatie
s’est alors déployée dans la direction
imaginée par Kant dans de la paix
perpétuelle un ordre politique
international se construit en vertu
duquel les états s'agressent plus
difficilement que par le passé l'idée
certes contestable d'une communauté
internationale prote ctrice de la paix
pénètre l'opinion publique enfin comme
l'escontéquente les citoyens des
démocraties contemporaines sont
réticents à supporter les coûts des
conflits armés
la violence suscite un rejet spontané
qui demande à être élucidé l'idée que
l'agression est une déviation du
comportement humain paraît satisfaisante
pour expliquer la stigmatisation de la
violence par la morale sociale en effet
le besoin de sécurité la force de
l'empathie et l'intérêt collectif à la
paix donne ta pensée que la violence
humaine est une aberration mais cette
idée se révèle fragile l'abondance et la
diversité des phénomènes de violence
inspirent au contraire l'hypothèse que
l'agression appartient au registre
ordinaire du comportement humain
l'épreuve accrédit-on cette hypothèse ne
sont pas minces la pression de la survie
la logique pernicieuse de l'honneur et
l'omniprésence des guerres dans
l'histoire de l'humanité la réalité de
la violence ne justifie pas pour autant
un retour aux fatalisme des Grecs les
hommes sont à la vérité de moins en
moins violents les états leur imposent
de résoudre leurs conflit par des
processus légaux et la morale sociale
ostracise les individus qui échouent à
contrôler leur agressivité enfin cette
pacification des rapports individuels
semble se reproduire à l'échelle des
nations peut-être suffira-t-il de
cultiver le droit plutôt que la
virtuosité sexuelle des bonobos
si tu aimes l'esprit de cette vidéo à
savoir travailler avec des idées claires
pour être le plus efficace possible
alors tu devrais t'inscrire à mes 50
paragraphes tout cuits sur le thème de
la violence ce sont 50 paragraphes prêts
à l'emploi qui couvrent tous les
arguments possibles sur le thème de la
violence avec dans chaque paragraphe la
référence idéale la plupart du temps
classique mais aussi parfois original
pour justifier l'argument ils sont
accompagnés d'une cinquantaine de
plantes détaillées modèles qui
permettent de traiter tous les sujets
possibles du coup tu réussiras
facilement tes dissertations sans
apprendre ton cours sans chercher un
plan ni des arguments et sans rédiger le
développement tu seras scandaleusement
surnommé grâce au style simple fluide
efficace et facile à imiter avec lequel
je rédige les paragraphes enfin mes 50
paragraphes tout cuits c'est aussi la
solution la plus rapide pour préparer un
DS grâce à la playlist audio tes
révisions se résumeront à écouter les
paragraphes pendant une heure dans
toutes les circonstances imaginables en
marchant en courant dans les transports
à la salle de sport ou encore au fond de
la classe par exemple Léa m'a raconté
qu'elle écoutait les paragraphes en
faisant du vélo d'appartement et qui un
moment donné qu'elle en faisait chaque
jour elle savait tout ce qu'elle avait
besoin de savoir pour ces dissertations
de culture générale sans avoir passé une
seule minute dans son cours comme ça
fait 7 ans que je propose mes
paragraphes tout cuits j'ai reçu
beaucoup d'autres témoignages regarde
celui-ci qui date de 2017 l'année
dernière je plafonnais à 8 en
dissertation j'étais dans les tout
derniers aujourd'hui le prof rend les
copies je major la classe avec 17
effectivement l'avantage de mes
paragraphes tout cuits c'est que tu
gagnes des points rapidement pas dans
six mois mais dès le prochain ds le
prochain témoignage est celui d'Alex il
m'a écrit sur messenger je me suis
rappelé que je ne t'avais jamais
remercié pour ta méthode qui m'a on peut
le dire sauver Alex dit que mes
paragraphes tout cuits ont sauvé parce
que la culture générale n'était pas sa
matière forte et qu'en plus il ne l'a
quasiment pas travaillé avec son niveau
il pensait se ramasser au concours mais
il a fini avec 13 à HEC et 15 à l'échec
la prestigieuse école qu'il a intégré le
dernier témoignage que je veux te
montrer est un peu drôle Roland m'écrit
même si j'ai eu 15 sur 20 je pense que
c'est plutôt grâce constater paragraphes
tout cuit très bien rédigé que grâce à
ma dissertation Roland pense qu'il a été
surnommé parce que le style de mes
paragraphes tout de suite a fait sortir
sa copie du Lot je sais j'ai promis que
c'était le dernier témoignage mais je
veux quand même t'en montrer un tout
dernier parce que c'est celui d'un prof
j'ai flouté beaucoup de choses dans son
email parce qu'il est prof de culture
générale dans une prépa prestigieuse en
plus d'être correcteur à HEC il m'écrit
notamment votre méthode est excellente
et correspond tout à fait à ce que je
crois est très efficace pour la
préparation des concours j'ai même
rencontré ce prof il m'a avoué qu'il
faisait désormais la même chose que moi
il prépare des paragraphes modèles pour
sa classe voilà je t'ai déjà montré un
témoignage de plus que ce que j'avais
promis il y en a encore beaucoup
d'autres sur la page de présentation si
tu veux en savoir plus sur mes
paragraphes tout cuits clique sur le
lien qui apparaît en haut à droite de la
vidéo ou bien clique sur celui qui est
dans la description ou bien encore tape
directement 1000 idées
cg.com/50ptc dans la barre de recherche
et puis si tu as des questions écris-moi
à
romain@miedc.com bon courage pour le
travail
[Musique]